what I want to do in this video is give
an introduction to the language or some
of the some of the some of the
characters that we use when we talk
about geometry and I guess the best
place to start is even think about what
geometry means and depending on how your
Latin is you might recognize the first
part of geometry right over here you
have the root word geo the same word
that you see in things like geography
and geology and this comes this refers
to the earth this refers myyy looks like
a sea right over there this refers to
the earth and then you see this metri
part and you see metree and things like
trigonometry as well and metree or the
metric system and this comes from
measurement this comes from measurement
or measure measurement so when someone's
talking about geometry the word itself
comes from earth measurement and that's
kind of not so bad of a name because it
is such a general subject geometry
really is the study and and trying to
understand how shapes and space and and
and things that we see relate to each
other so you know and when you start
learning about geometry you learn about
lines and triangles and circles and you
learn about angles and will define all
of these things more and more precisely
as we go further and further on but also
encapsulate things like patterns and and
three-dimensional shapes so it's it's
almost everything that we see of all the
math visually mathematical things that
we understand can in some way be
categorized in geometry now with that
out of the way let's just start from the
basics a basic starting point from
geometry and then we can just grow from
there so if we just start at a dot that
dot right over there it's just a point
it's just that that little point on that
screen right over there we'd literally
call that a point and I'll call that a
definition and the fun thing about
mathematics is that you can make
definitions you we could have called
this and we could have called this an
armadillo but we decide to call this a
point which I think makes sense because
it's what we would call it in just
everyday language as well that is a
point now what's interesting about a
point is that it is just a position that
you can't move on a point if you moved
you were at this point and if you moved
in any direction at all you would no
longer be at that point so you cannot
move on a point now there are
differences between points for example
that's one point there may be I have
another point over here and then I have
another point over here and then another
point over there and you want to be able
to refer to the different points and not
everyone has the luxury of a nice
colored pen like I do cause they could
refer to the green point or the blue
point or the pink point and so in
geometry to refer to points we tend to
give them labels and the labels tend to
have letters so for example this could
be point a this could be point B this
would be point C and this right over
here could be point D so someone says
hey Circle Point C you know which one to
circle you know that you would have to
circle you would have to circle that
point right over there well that's so
far is it's kind of interesting you have
these things called points you really
can't move around on a point all they do
is specify a position what if we want to
move around a little bit more what if we
want to get from one point to another so
what if we took we started at one point
and we wanted to cut we wanted all of
the points including that point that
connect that point at another point so
all of these points right over here so
what would we call what would we call
this thing all of the points that
connect a and B along a straight and
I'll use everyday language here along
kind of a straight line like this well
we'll call this a line segment in
everyday language you might call it a
line but we'll call it a line segment
because we'll see and when we talk in
mathematical terms a line means
something slightly different so this is
a line segment and if we were to connect
D and C this would also be another line
segment a line segment and once again
because then we always don't have the
luxury of colors this one is clear the
orange line segment this is clearly the
yellow line segment we want to have
labels for these line segments and the
best way to label the line segments are
with its endpoints and that's another
word here so a point is just literally a
or B but a and B are also the endpoints
of these line segments because it starts
and ends at a and B so let me write this
a
and B a and B are endpoints another
definition right over here we once again
we could have called them aardvarks or
end armadillos but we as mathematicians
decide to call them endpoints because
that seems to be a good name for it and
once again we need a way to label these
line segments with with that have the
endpoints and what's a better way to
label a line segment then with its
actual endpoints so we would refer to
this line segment over here we would put
its endpoints there and to show that
it's a line segment we would draw a line
over it just like that this line segment
down here we would write it like this
and we could have just as easily written
it like this CD with a line over it
would have referred to that same line
segment ba ba
with a line segment with a line over it
would refer to that same line segment
now you might be saying well I'm not
satisfied just travelling in between a
and B and this is actually another
interesting idea when you were just on a
when you're just on a point and you
couldn't travel at all you couldn't
travel all in any direction without
while staying on that point that means
you have you have zero options to travel
in you can't go up or down left to right
in or out of the page and still be on
that point and so that's why we say a
point has zero dimensions zero
dimensions now all of a sudden we have
this thing this line segment here and
this line segment we can at least go to
the left and the right along this line
segment we can go towards a or towards B
so we can go back or forward in one
dimension so the line segment is a
one-dimensional it is a one-dimensional
idea almost or one dimensional object
although these are more kind of abstract
ideas there is no such thing as a
perfect line segment because everything
a line segment you can't move you can't
move up or down on this line segment
while being on it while in reality
anything that we think is a line segment
even you know
a stick of some type of very state
straight stick or a string that is taut
that still will have some width but the
geometrical pure line segment has no
width it only has a length year so you
can only move along the line and that's
why we say it's one dimensional a point
you can't move at all a line segment you
can only move in that back and forth
along that same direction now I just
hinted that it can actually have a
length how do you refer to that
well you refer to that by not writing
that line on it so if I write a B with
the line on top of it like that that
means I'm referring to the actual line
segment if I say that let me do this in
a new color
if I say that a B is equal to five units
it might be centimeters or meters or
whatever just the abstract units v that
means that the distance between a and B
is five that the length of line segment
a B is actually five now let's keep on
extending it let's say we want to just
keep going in one direction so let's say
that I started a let me do this in a new
color let's say I started a and I want
to go to D but I want to I want the
option of keep on I want to keep on
going so I can't go further in A's
direction than a but I can go further in
DS direction so this little this this
this idea that I just showed this
essentially it's like a line segment but
I can keep on going past this endpoint
we call this we call this a ray and the
starting point for ray is called the
vertex not a term that you'll see too
often you'll see vertex later on in
other contexts but it's good to know
this is the vertex of of the Ray it's
not the vertex of this line segment so
maybe I shouldn't label it just like
that and what's interesting about
a-reits once again a one-dimensional
figure but you could keep on going in
one of the direct you can keep on going
tour past one of the endpoints and the
way that we would specify array is we
would say we call it ad and we would put
this little arrow over on top of it
to show that it is array and in this
case it matters the order that we put
the letters in if I put da if I put da
as a ray this would mean a different
rate that would mean that we're
starting at D and then we're going past
a so this is not radiate this is Ray a D
now the last idea that I'm sure you're
thinking about is well what if I could
keep on going in every in both
directions so let's say I can keep going
in let me my diagram is getting messy so
let's let me introduce some more points
so let's say I have point E and then I
have point F right over here and let's
say that I have this object that can
that goes through both E and F but just
keeps on going in both directions this
is when we talk in geometry terms this
is what we call a line now notice a line
never ends you can keep going in either
direction a line segment does end it has
endpoints a line does not and that's
your line segment can sometimes be
called just a segment and so you would
specify line EF you would specify line
EF with these arrows just like that now
the thing that you're gonna see most
typically when we're studying geometry
are these right over here because we're
gonna be concerned with sides of shapes
distances between points and we're
talking about any of those things things
that have finite length things that have
an actual length things that don't go
off forever in one or two directions
then you're talking about a segment or a
line segment now if we go back to a line
segment just to kind of keep talking
about new words that you might confront
in geometry if we go back talking about
a line that's um I was drawing a ray so
let's say I have point X and point y and
so this is line segment XY so I can
specify it denote it just like that if I
have another point let's say I have
another point right over here let's call
that point Z and I'll introduce another
word XY and z are on the same they all
lie on the same line if you would
imagine that a line could keep going on
and on forever and ever so we can say
that x y&z are collinear
so those three points Arco that they are
collinear they all sit on the same line
or and they also all sit on line segment
XY now let's say we know we're told that
X
Z is equal to Z Y and they are all
collinear so that means this is telling
us that the distance between X and Z is
the same as the distance between Z and y
so sometimes we can we can mark it like
that this distance is the same as that
distance over there so that tells us
that Z is exactly halfway between x and
y so in this situation we would call Z
the midpoint the midpoint of of line
segment X Y because it's exactly halfway
between now to finish up we've talked
about things that have zero dimensions
points we've talked about things that
have one dimension a line a line segment
or array you might say well what has two
dimensions well in order to have two
dimensions that means I can go backwards
and forwards in two different directions
so this this page right here or this
video or the screen that you're looking
at is a two dimensional object I can go
I can go right left that is one
dimension or I can go up down and so
this this this this this this surface of
the monitor you're looking at is
actually two dimensions two dimensions
you can go backwards or forwards in two
directions and things that are two
dimensions we call them planar or we
call them planes so if you took a if you
took a a piece of paper that extended
forever just said it just extended in
every direction forever that in the
geometrical sense was a plane the piece
of paper itself the thing that's finite
and you'll never see this talked about
in a in a typical geometry class but I
guess if we were to draw the analogy you
could call a piece of paper maybe a
plane segment because it's a segment of
an entire plane if you had a third
dimension then you're talking about kind
of our three-dimensional space in
three-dimensional space not only could
you move left or right along the screen
or up and down you could also move in
and out of this screen you can also have
this dimension that I'll try to draw you
could go into the screen or you could go
out of the screen like that and and and
as we go into higher and higher
mathematics although it becomes very
hard to visualize you'll see that we can
even start to study things that have
more than three dimensions